hello and welcome to this video this is
some just a quick wooded game to +1 in
case y display doesn't ya know she or he
display this is for audio yeah I got
some feedback on the audio being bad and
I do understand to the point I fiddled a
lot with my audio over the time in
various yeah with with changing devices
with all kinds of things I had always
sounded bad anyway
what I did is actually to now change
some settings in the OBS software and it
is I never changed the settings in OBS
because I only relatively recently
switched to that software so it's
something and then I wanted to try and I
did so please tell me how this sounds
um one issue that I always have with the
sounder set my own hearing is not great
so I sometimes simply don't hear those
noises that get described to me like the
sounds bad there is bad growl noises
this and that I don't hear it
I just don't hear it so it's difficult
for me to actually judge if I have
decent audio or if it is bad or if there
is a certain specific problem I
sometimes just don't hear it
and sometimes people tell me how your
audio is bad and I don't I would not
agree simply because I don't hear the
the noises so um in the meantime I
played this game yeah just putting a
London system on the board and it's a
two plus one bullet game so um yeah I
mostly just played quick moves and did
not pay all that close attention I have
a good position though night xt6
I do have
d three and then I'd be five okay it's
not a problem I can just take him and
also think I'm okay ninety-five is an
interesting move now because I don't
know where the bishop is going to go and
who there is night III also on the
agenda I think white is in trouble here
there is no good move now for white
yeah let me know what do you think about
the audio it would be great to learn how
you experience the change
you
now I'm good do this c4 is a move that
doesn't help why do all that much
they keep playing fast I didn't want to
play one zero because I felt then I
don't have enough time to explain some
points about the audio but I also didn't
want to play like a fool
full-scale five-minute game okay
sure that this diagonal is is open
[Music]
it's it's an increment but still yeah so
it's just not a lot of time yeah and
wide resigned yeah I don't really want
to analyze the game it was just a quick
way of getting a game going
yeah please let me know how this sounded
thanks a lot for watching the test video